thank you so much for the comment so far
I've really enjoyed reading them but
best of all you guys made me think of
things that I hadn't even thought of so
the answers I talk about here include
perspectives from you guys and I really
do value that this is a dialogue so
please do leave comments about what you
think first on the question of
determinism in quantum mechanics there's
a few ways to see this and it depends on
how you see the wavefunction if you
believe the wavefunction is really
everything you can know about an object
even in theory then the Schrodinger
equation says this the state of the
particle not just what you know about
the state but the actual state is
determined in the future provided that
you don't make a measurement that simply
is the definition of determinism and so
in this view quantum mechanics is
deterministic up to the point of
measurement however people pointed out
that if you don't think that the
wavefunction is the state but rather
tells you about the uncertainty you have
about the state for example in bohmian
mechanics then there is uncertainty
right from the beginning but what I
wonder is isn't the opposite of
determinism randomness not uncertainty
also even in the case with uncertainty
doesn't the Schrodinger equation tell
you how to update your uncertainty so
would you accept that as a formal form
of determinism or not as for measurement
in bohmian mechanics my take on it is
that the outcome is uncertain but not
random making bohmian mechanics
deterministic many-worlds is an
interpretation that I want to make
videos about eventually but it's also
deterministic because it doesn't accept
that measurement causes collapse
instead all possible outcomes happen the
second question was me asking you to
prove this statement this is my proof
and I'll put it up on the screen but as
for what it would mean if it wasn't true
many people had some great answers about
why that wouldn't make any sense say you
started with this state and you're
watching it as time goes by at time t1
you see that it's this then you check
again after t2 amount of time and so you
update the static
but then say your friend had only
checked on the state once at the very
end then their state is this but you
should both agree I mean there is only
one state this rule is very obvious but
it's something that you really want your
time evolution to have now remember when
I was picking what angle of rotation we
wanted I said it should depend on T but
why not on T squared or something else
because only teen would obey this rule
verify that for yourself third this one
is some mats too and it goes like this
say I have a superposition of some
states and then you want to show this
well what you should do is write each of
these in the energy eigenbasis since
time evolution is really easy in that
basis and then add all the factors in
but now compare that to the time
evolution of each of these individual
parts and you can see that these two
things are equal
now sorry this is a bit rushed but like
I said I'd really like to keep up the
discussion so please comment with any
thoughts